the first thing I want to ask you guys
when you were making this movie did you
expect it to be the hit that it is we
had an idea because we didn't know where
it was going to be shown or if it would
be shown at all so when it's sold to
Netflix we we were shocked it's not
every day that a zippy burr with the
prison for murder for hire how did you
feel about the way that it all came
together I mean do you feel you were
portrayed accurately not at all I mean
they you know they misled us we didn't
do anything we didn't we didn't rat on
Joe we didn't snitch on Joe my name is
Joe exotic and this is Sarge
it was like a mythical character living
out in the middle of [ __ ] Oklahoma
who owned 1200 tigers and lions and
bears and [ __ ] no what would you want to
clear up then we never set out to hurt
Joe we we came here to actually save Joe
Lauren and I lived in a beautiful home
in Colorado as you saw in that video Joe
came out he tried to solicit us to come
here and bail him out and it worked I
mean we came back we bailed him out we
got the park back on its feet making my
meal out a guy who you didn't know why I
save a guy who you just know what it's a
it's a very small family the exotic
gamma industry Lorne and I made a visit
you see all these beautiful animals
knowing that someone like Carol masks
and was going to possibly get all of
them and I didn't want them to happen
anyway are we hearing tigers right now
but you know Carol had a judgment
against Joe for a million dollars and
there's very few assets that Joe
actually owned and we did not want her
getting hold of these tigers because she
would have either she would raise money
she lent me money or figure out a way to
put him down she's had more tigers died
in her possession than Joe ever had so
we came back and we helped Joe get out
of trouble we then we just couldn't deal
with him I mean Joe is a difficult
person to be around
so I told Lorna so this move to Vegas
it's sad that people think that we set
him up but what we did was we protected
ourselves Lauren and I didn't do
anything wrong so I'm not about to take
the fall for Joe's crimes so when the
feds started investigating Joe and we
were tipped off by
the confidential informant that do not
come back to the park Joe's under
investigation we knew that we had no
choice we had to tell them what we knew
we handed over our cell phones our bank
accounts our whatever they asked for we
gave and cooperated fully and you know
it's just sad that they wanted to
portray it like my arrest my arrest in
Las Vegas was like a traffic ticket we
had we we were ticked I was cited for
doing business without a license because
we had a commercial vehicle in my
driveway we had two baby tigers in our
house we always say baby tigers in our
house in your opinion give me a
percentage how accurate is the
docu-series the talk.you series is
pretty close you know it they missed a
lot it's what they told they told pretty
well and Joe has had this you know this
passion for having Caroll Baskin killed
for years and years before we ever knew
him every person that came into this
park that he thought was capable of
killing somebody he asked
he's solicited I bet you 200 people to
do a job they'll have a harder than the
soul and mind I've learned from them but
Carroll blasek and hate saying I can't
have a tiger if he ever had an enemy in
his life it was Carroll bastard I gotta
ask you guys then for the record were
you part of a plot to kill Carol baskets
why why you know absolutely not
did I bring up a map on Google Maps yes
I did
I absolutely did I told the feds this
the first time we spoke that was because
despite what Chucky says we were in the
office and my off my desk sits right at
the front door Joerg Joe's is in the
back and there's always three or four
people in the office hanging around
Joe's husband Travis came in and Joe had
gotten up and says he says hey yeah I
love that map
it's house so Travis is stand behind me
on Google Earth it and because Joe had
gone to some convention in in Clearwater
he came back from a convention he says I
got I found out where these lives and he
posted a picture I think it I think they
showed it on the dock
that he posted on Facebook that I found
the bitch's house and so we knew where
it was we knew generally the vicinity of
it so I was able to bring it up on and
just show Travis with bets that's my
participation in this
[Music]
now
I saw tang
Joe has been a criminal his entire life
that's not Joe singing in the you know
he doesn't sing that's all fake he's
just a big fraud and if those five
Tigers were the only ones he killed it
would be refreshing but we know that
he's killed
he's killed 50 or 60 Tigers you know
that we know of and those five Tigers we
knew exactly where they were buried we
knew exactly how they died so it was the
easiest for authorities to explain to a
jury to not only my recording studio but
the studio that houses our alligators
which caused him all to burna and perish
boiling a lot in a towering inferno
nothing but flames and fire I know Joe
didn't do it personally because Joe was
in Chicago at a funeral but I think Joe
had it done too
for two reasons one to conceal the fact
that he stoled video from the guy who's
filming Joe's exactly TV show he had
that video on the safe the safe was open
when they when the fire investigators
came and Joe was under subpoena by Carol
Baskins attorneys to turn over hard
drives and computers and the hard drives
and the computers were all missing and
the safe was empty when the fire
investigators came said Joe was the only
one with a motive what do you think
happened to Carol Baskins former husband
Don I think he I think she discovered
that he was going to leave her leave her
with with much of nothing and she was
not about to let that happen
so she was a street savvy young lady who
who decided that she needed to protect
her her lifestyle I you're being a lot
more eloquent actually than doc antal
was and I talked to him he just said
several times she killed her husband
kill it
apparently the sheriff posted and said
look because of the renewed interest the
cases open tips are coming in that you
heard of anything potentially coming to
light in his missing-persons case we've
heard certain things we've heard names
of who people think helped her we you
know the meat grinder that they showed
in the video or she she scoffed at the
fact that DOM could be put through a
meat grinder that was four inches that's
not the meat grinder that we know if she
had so and we've been told that there's
a police report
someplace in Hillsborough County that
where Carole's filed it claiming that
her one of her buildings was broken into
and her meat grinders were stolen how
did you see one of her meat grinders I
we just know of people who work there
and yeah so have you inherited the
battle with Carroll Baskins is she
coming after you guys now that you have
the zoo I think Carol's got her hands
full you know she can she can have this
place when you leave she can she can
walk in here Nev every square inch of
this property I don't care
oh so you guys are isolating with a
bunch of big exotic animals and also
with your new little one right maybe
she's doing really good I don't want to
shock you but everyone wanted me to ask
if if your nanny is around as well she's
not she's actually I'm back at home
right now I'm tying up some loose ends
cuz she's like kind of going back and
forth right now okay we heard the nanny
we heard the nanny to be with us down at
the new zoo because we know be too busy
and because we keep pushing that back it
kept screwing up her schedule she's an
Instagram model in Las Vegas and she she
was she comes in on a regular basis just
to get to know the baby but she won't
start with us full-time until we get
down to factor though well look you know
you're shown saying why wouldn't you
hire somebody who looks great you've
also been
are portrayed as look you guys you guys
swing people say so so is the nanny yet
another girlfriend is coming to the
picture the conclusion everybody drop
would I be a gentleman like if I kissed
and told no she's she's not she's just
she's just a sweet girl who's helping us
out well that is a sweet baby hi well
how did you guys feel about your your
romantic lifestyle being shared was that
something you expected you know what
they they blew that a little bit out of
proportion we have fun and we like to
you know hang out Marty but you know
it's it's amazing that anybody cares as
soon as your life is made public
everybody has something to say about it
we're here in the middle of Winnie wood
Oklahoma our pickings are slim and Las
Vegas I might have answered the question
differently but here we're just here
every day you know taking care of these
animals well you are gonna have the
nanny soon if you want to interview
later whenever she does come back right
in my lap are you already hooking up
with the nanny
I don't know you we saw it you said see
I I hired somebody who looks great and
who's nice to look at so you got it you
gotta ask the question you know are you
married I'm divorced because well would
you have let that name come into your
house it's a special kind of you you're
a lucky guy is what you're saying I am a
lucky guy look again
well you're that little one is so
beautiful so congrats we're taking
applications for a publicist and
assistant in a maid oh my god
and do you need photos attached to each
of those applications yes please
measurements photos
alright Network
[Music]